we're at PI data Austin it's Saturday
sorry this is objectionable content
December 7th 2019 this is a talk about
the Python object model my name is James
Powell if you like this talk you can
follow me on Twitter I don't use this
code in fact you might want to open that
up right now because the screen may not
be large enough for you to see in the
audience so I've put up teammate link on
my Twitter feed so that you can follow
along on your computer and watch
everything I'm doing on my screen
without having to squint at the poor
resolution in front of you here so
before I get started with this tutorial
rather I want to just briefly touch upon
why this is a topic that anybody at a PI
data conference should ever care about
what we're gonna talk about here is
almost entirely going to be about how
Python works how the object model in
Python works how design of systems with
the Python object model works and we're
gonna touch upon almost no scientific
computing and almost no absolutely no
machine learning and probably very
little data science or anything similar
to data science as an anecdote I was
very recently working with a company
that silicon photonics and the work that
they do is very deeply scientific and
very deeply mathematical however that
work is situated within a production
context they're not doing research for
silicon photonics they're actually going
and producing physical pieces of
hardware and so while as part of that
work they may employ machine learning in
order to figure out yield predictions or
in order to look at images of the chips
and try and figure out if those chips
are going to fail or not in production
fundamentally they have some kind of
production process whereby their design
needs to incorporate into some system
which can go and produce these chips
there's a lot of production level
programming beyond just the analytical
side and as part of my work with them
trying to train some of their scientists
to be able to use Python more
effectively we looked at a couple of
sample problems that were relevant to
them it turns out and it's quite
surprising to me that there's very
little work in layout and placement for
silicon photonics and well that's not
exactly the example that we use here
we'll use a much simplified example that
might touch or be within spitting
distance of that fundamentally in order
to do a layout system you're gonna have
to figure out how to write a business
rule system in order write a business
rule system you're going to
to figure out how to use Python more
effectively than just writing functions
and so for many of you in your use of
Python as a data scientist or as a
machine learning expert you may have
really only gone so far as to write
maybe a couple of functions you might
play around with keyword arguments in
Python you might have written a couple
of classes but you've never had to write
large system design and what I try and
convey to you in this talk is that that
kind of large system design is necessary
the moment your analytical work its
situated in some kind of business
context and somebody needs to do
something real with it for example to
drive some automated testing process or
in order to drive some yield
optimization process your code your
analytical code can't stand alone and so
you have to branch away from just using
your numpy ndra directly or your pandas
data frames directly to do some analysis
you have to start building systems and
mechanisms around that now I have a very
brief agenda for you we've got about 90
minutes for this tutorial and I'm not
sure how the timing will work out but
I'll spend as much time as I can showing
you a couple of things that you may or
may not know this is a pretty novice
level tutorial so there may be some
content at the beginning that you're
already very familiar with and then once
I show you some things we'll try some
things we'll work on an example perhaps
together in order to that we'll may make
use of what we see about the Python
object model in order to actually design
some kind of system now I suspect that
we won't have enough time in the example
portion to complete this example the
example that I'll show you in a moment
is about modeling simple linear planar
circuits and automatically computing
what the current and voltage at
different points are there's a little
bit of mathematical work in there and we
may not get as far as that but hopefully
we'll get just far enough to think about
how we would design a tool that could do
that using what we see in this first
portion okay and so let's get started so
this is me on Twitter you can see that
teammate link there if you click on it
you'll see something that looks like
this this is the session that I'm going
to be working out of and so if you go to
my Twitter feed that don't use this code
and you click on that link you won't
have to squint at the screen up here and
also all the people at home who follow
me on Twitter will get to see this talk
for free but they won't get the audio so
they'll have to figure out what we're
doing now let's get started
let's talk about Python objects and the
Python data model and we'll start very
simply I mean a lot of your data
scientists and really when we talk about
Python objects the most you may have
ever touched upon is maybe a panda's
data frame or numpy ndra and some dotted
methods on it instead of saying you know
sort of from numpy import some you did
you know numpy ndra dot some and you
know that there's methods and there's
attributes on these objects we haven't
gotten that much further and a lot of
your code you may just work pretty much
almost entirely with the built-in types
and so it may be the case that if we had
a simple program that was trying to
model like a simple circuit we might
start by modeling each of the components
of that circle it's just a tuple and
when we can see if we do that you know
we get a simple tuple type and it has
some fields associated with it and
there's nothing too complex about that
now we actually try to interact with
that we have to access the fields of
this tuple and we'll see that that's
going to be a little bit unpleasant we
have to use direct field accessing and
it's kind of ugly it's not clear to us
what component 0 1 2 or 3 might be if
this block of code that's accessing the
fields is very far away from this block
of code but you know it kind of works
and we might at some points do you know
make use of tuple D structuring in order
to give names to these fields so it
might be structure this into four
different variables and then access
those variables directly and that's kind
of nice but we still have this
fundamental problem that the tuple when
you D structure it you need to know the
order of the fields themselves and if
this code here is very far away from
this code here it may be very difficult
to keep these two in sync what we might
then try is you might try something a
little bit fancier it might say you know
what I want to be able to access the
fields of this object directly I want to
have some self documenting behavior here
so instead I'll use a dictionary and the
keys the dictionary will be the field
and the values the dictionary will be
the actual value on that field and so
that that kind of works there's nothing
too fancy there when I go about
accessing the fields it's not altogether
that difficult I just use my square
bracket indexing for the dictionary and
it's a little bit ugly a little bit
clumsy I have to add square brackets I
have to have these single quotes or
double quotes but it's a little bit
nicer than the tuple in that if I were
to add fields later I don't have to go
and change all the code that I've
already written and visually it's a
little bit closer to being self
documenting now I might then try
something very simple II maybe for
example I'm a JavaScript program
and I really like how JavaScript the
objects and JavaScript can be accessed
using the square bracket syntax or the
dotted syntax so I create something like
an adder dict and I just override the
get adder set adder and Dell adder for a
Python object so it just calls the Dixon
get item set item and Dell item and so
here I have effectively the same code as
before except now I can access the
fields by name using this dotted syntax
just like I can in JavaScript now this
is kind of silly and please don't ever
do this this is a really bad idea
it doesn't gain you a whole lot and I
don't know why people just really seem
to hate typing those extra square
brackets and the double quotes but if
you really think about it you really
dive a little bit deeper and you think
is it that silly it's not really that
silly because if we were to write this
as a normal Python object you know I
just a regular class with an init method
I'm going to look at that class we'll
see that inside that class there's a
attribute called dict with two
underscores before and after and it's
pretty much the same dictionary as a
dictionary above and that dict object is
where it's storing all the instance
state so we might say you know what this
adder structure despite being a
very bad idea and by the way if you try
and look up how to write that there's
two formulations that you'll see people
talk about online and one of them is a
terrible terrible formulation where you
set the dict
of the instance to itself and you end up
with potential memory pressure because
it has a circular reference and so when
the garbage collector tries to collect
this there's some delay in its
collection and so don't do it at all but
if you're gonna do it use a formulation
I showed you above however what argument
you might make is that it's not
altogether that different than how
Python dictionaries are actually
implemented under the covers now if we
try that one of the things that we might
have run across if we ever done some
object modeling and Python is we have
some system and we have lots of these
kind of resistor objects because we're
modeling humongous circuits and we're
seeing that's using a lot of memory and
it turns out that this formulation of
the Python object that has this dict
object inside of it representing all of
the instance date does use a lot of
memory and so we can look at this object
and we can ask the system the system
what's the size of this thing
miss this module will tell us how its 48
bytes in size and so it's pretty big for
one individual piece of data that really
doesn't store a whole lot of information
some part number some manufacturer and
just a resistance presumably in base
units and ohms of this component now if
we were to really get a bug about us to
try and do some kind of management or
some sort of analysis of the memory use
of our program we could go pretty far
there's quite a few tools in Python
especially in Python 3 for doing memory
management there's a trace malloc module
and the trace malloc module you can take
snapshots and when you take snapshots
you can see what got allocated in
between those two snapshots and so for a
very simple example like this we could
see is this thing really as large as I
thought it was and if you actually run
this you can see on average this line 11
which is the creation of this one object
indicated had 48 bytes of additional
memory allocated so it probably takes
about 48 bytes to store this structure
which is still very large but at least
we have some fixed bound on how big it
is and we can play around with trying to
make it smaller now bear in mind another
thing I would never advise you to do is
the moment anybody gives you a project
that's our applications using too much
memory can you figure out how to reduce
that amount of memory and by the way
it's written in Python just find a new
job because it's those projects are
always giant dead ends because even
though this analysis kind of looks like
it works it only works like this because
we're dealing with very simple heap
allocated Python objects the moment you
start to do memory analysis on large
Python programs you'll see that there
are structures within a Python
interpreter like free lists in your
attribute lookup mechanism that never
get D allocated so an actual Python
program may not necessarily deallocate
memory that it no longer uses it'll just
hit a high-water mark and stay at that
water mark so all of these exercises
where somebody says oh our app is using
a gigabyte of memory and how do you
improve the memory usage and then you go
and you try and change a bunch of things
you won't be able to get the effects
that you think you might be able to get
and fundamentally unless you really
understand what memory means on all the
platforms or your application runs like
on your Windows platform you understand
what that VSS and an RSS and all that
means or when you do free at your Linux
terminal you understand what all those
numbers mean it's a dead end and so we
won't go any deeper into this example
because this is pretty much a dead end
career-wise if you ever get a project
like that and also analytically because
the typical the typical answer to this
in Python is to use a mechanism
by the Python object model called slots
which no longer or in which a Python
object no longer has an instance
dictionary so you save all that memory
from that extra dictionary and instead
you have explicit locations for where
the instance date of that type is stored
and so here this particular object
cannot store additional information
outside of the number of manufacturer
resistance if I try to amend this to add
another field at runtime it'll fail you
can see it'll fail it doesn't have that
attribute and so it loses that dynamic
behavior in exchange for presumably
being a little bit smaller in fact but
in fact in this case it's not smaller
it's actually bigger and so you can see
just don't don't bother with memory
analysis and Python it's not worth your
time now what you should do instead and
the guidance that I should give you it's
a very important very high-level piece
of guidance for whenever you're writing
a program or even working on the example
that we're going to look at you know
after we go through some of these topics
is to think about Python as an
orchestration language Python was
originally called back in the day when
we were trying to popularize Python
though the ultimate glue language the
ultimate orchestration language a
language which takes components that are
written in other languages like C or C++
and orchestrates they're mechanisms
inside those components which might be
some kind of analytical code that
somebody wrote ten years ago that nobody
wants to rewrite but we don't want to
today be designing experiments or
setting up models and still using malloc
and free wanna have a nicer interface
for that well then we reserved the
manipulation of the problem the
manipulation of the business entities or
the manipulation of the experiment to
the Python level and the actual core
computational use to this library and C
or C++ or Fortran or whatever it might
be and so those entities turn into what
I like to call restricted computation
domains a very common one that you're
almost certainly familiar with is the uh
numpy and D array if you think about it
a Python object is always boxed there's
no distinction in Python between boxed
and unboxed objects like there is in
Java and Python everything is boxed and
so everything is an object that you can
call methods on that also is heap
allocated and takes or with the
exception of certain things that might
be interned or other optimizations but
for the most part or heap allocated and
take a large amount of space
whereas with the numpy NDA the contents
of an umpire in the array are contiguous
machine types so they're unboxed well
what happens in Python is you often
design your system so that you have
business entities that are unboxed
entities then you put them into a
computation domain like a numpy and
array or a panda's data frame inside
that computation domain they get unboxed
so that the computation domain which
restricts your access to those entities
can then perform certain specializations
and optimizations for example putting
these in some kind of cache contiguous
structure so that you can do fast sums
or taking Python integers and turning
them into machine integers with specific
bit widths so then you can use processor
level instructions in order to compute
operations on them and you can see more
or less that pattern occurs in any code
example uses pandas or numpy or network
X or any of these other tools and so in
the case of numpad you might see some
code that looks like this you have three
unboxed Python integers you put them
into an umpire and dra you perform some
computation inside that array once it's
inside that ndra because it is a
restricted computation to me because
numpy says these are machine types there
they are
they are fixed bit with integers so they
are in 64's there is no inter
dependencies between these items it can
then choose to perform this element-wise
multiplication in whatever fashion it
finds is most efficient so it can auto
parallelize it or could use machine
level instructions or it could use some
kind of more sophisticated processor
level instructions to auto vector to
vectorize this multiplication and then
you pull them back out and so you can
see there's almost always this case of
you have the unboxed the boxed object
you put into the computation in main
which draws a box around everything the
objects themselves become unboxed and
then you pull them back out as boxed
objects and so this is tends to be the
pattern for where large object systems
work and so as we go through the example
one of the things you should think about
is any time you're working on some
production system in python and you're
modeling in terms of Python objects one
of the limitations that you have is it's
just gonna be slow it's gonna be slow
and it's gonna use a lot of memory and
it's gonna be slow and use a lot of
memory because python objects are heap
allocated they're not contiguous and so
even if you have computations that
should be local in some fashion you
won't get that locality in terms of
where the
chicks are in the heap and also they're
just huge right I mean in the previous
example we needed 48 bytes to store what
two strings and an int it's a lot of
space to store not a lot of data and the
reason is there's a lot of overhead for
a Python object you need to manage what
the type is you need to manage its
reference count and so forth and so on
and so what you should think is whenever
you're designing a system like that it
will inevitably turn into a situation
where you draw some box around the
business entity some manager box and
inside of that you create a computation
domain and then you restrict access to
it and that's how you get your
performance back and so one of the
things when I talk about this people
sometimes bring up is they like to say
well is a restricted computation domain
a monad and it's not really a monad you
think about monads you often think about
putting a box around items and
interacting with them only through some
specific API in relation to that box but
what makes a monad interesting I think
is the bind operation and there's really
no notion of a bind operation here and
also the ability to then provide
Combinator's on top of them we don't
have that this is a lot simpler than a
monad it's just some computation domain
that gives you the ability to specify
how the underlying data is stored and
how you process that aligned data so
what happens when you do these things in
Python is you end up having some kind of
Manager class and you're in the writing
code that looks like it has some manager
class that manages everything and so for
our resistor Network let's say we had
some product that had some resistors on
it we ought to provide some computation
on that maybe that computation would be
that we wanted to sum or find the mean
resistance of all these resistors and so
we might have some individual Python
object that represents this boxed
individual business entity that stores
information that's not computational
nature like the manufacturer and the
part number are not computational ninja
they're not used in any computations but
they're used for your production
management of that system for example
you ingest a bill of materials and that
bill of materials needs to know what's
the part number and what's the
manufacturer and what's the resistance
you then perform some computation
validate this product or this piece of
hardware and then you say ok I validated
it now who do I go and send shipping
orders to and so you need that business
information but it's not actually used
as part of the core computation then you
might have some computational entity and
that this product here represents this
computational entity it takes the
components that you give it in this case
just a bunch of resistors and it
extracts the information for them and
puts them into a pen
now if you remember how pin is not a
frame works internally it has this block
manager in the case of the pandas
dataframe here it'll probably be an
umpire nd right so effectively my
manager class then has an umpire in da
race which are now contiguous machine
typed structures where these
computations become very efficiently and
when I add a get item to pull items out
of this computation domain I can then
restore the boxed Python structure by
just reconstructing the resistor object
on the way out and so what you can see
here in this example is you know we
start with a product and we give it a
couple of Python objects it deconstruct
those Python objects to pull the
information out stores in an efficient
format and that pandas not a frame I can
then perform operations on it like I can
do a dot mean operation that will then
be performed in a very efficient fashion
and then I can ask it to give me the
object back out and they'll reconstruct
the object in the way out so this is how
these structures tend to look and you
wouldn't you really wouldn't do
something like this in C++ and C++ you'd
often just write a C++ object and you
assume that the you know zero cost
abstraction H or C++ would make this
automatically efficient and Python you
have to add this additional abstraction
that is just a layer because the pure
Python objects are very good for
orchestrating the operation you're
trying to perform but they're not very
good at performing or representing the
data in a fashion that is optimal for
computation so with that set aside let's
go back to our friend the tuple and we
probably don't want to really use a
tuple to represent any sort of dot in
our program even if we're doing you know
simple data analysis and all the only
sophisticated type we deal with is maybe
our input data and then we stick it into
an umpire in the array we probably won't
don't want to really use tuples pass
maybe the first prototyping stage
instead we might want to use something
like from the collections module the
name tuple which is just the mechanism
by which we can automatically generate
code that subclasses from a tuple object
and in that subclass in that automatic
generated code it gives you very nice
things like a nice principal
representation if we look at this code
you can see it gives us a very nice
printable representation of the
underlying object and we have this
dotted attribute access to these fields
so we don't have this unfortunate organ
ah mcc's of the under of the tuple where
we have to access the fields by position
and then if we add extra fields and we
have to go and update our existing
now the limitation of the name tuple is
that it's still a tuple and so you still
have that immutability which may or may
not be desirable for you but
fundamentally this is probably better
than your underlying two-pole structure
but if you were to show me some code and
you said I'm modeling some system and
it's in a production system and I
started by representing all of my
objects that's just built in Python
types tuples and dates did I do the
right thing or not the real answer to
learn from all of this is that one of
the design principles of Python is spend
more time with your family in other
words if you're given a task and that
task is loosely defined as most business
tasks in a production context are and
you're told I need you to do this one
specific task well then do the bare
minimum that you can do in order to
achieve that one requirement and what
you'll see as we go through some of
these examples is Python gives you
certain ways to take a very simple
representation of an object and to
increase its complexity as the
complexity of the requirements increase
and so the answer is not in Python to
take a C++ approach to designing an
object to designing your system and C++
may be the approach that you might take
is you first think really hard about the
underlying types that you're
representing and the operations between
them and you write everything out and if
you get it right
then each marginal requirement that you
get is only a very small marginal amount
of work and so you can think there's a
lot of upfront effort then a very small
marginal amount of work as you go and
Python we try to get something a little
bit more linear in the sense that you
produce a very marginal amount of work
today
wait until the requirement comes in and
then see if you can extend that without
causing changes to code that uses the
code that you've written and so things
like the elevation from bear tuple to a
named tuple in an example because if I
had started this example with just a
regular tuple other than the dotted look
up anywhere else so this code might be
used would work and so turning this into
a named tuple only turn this into rather
turning this here into a named tuple
just means that I add some functionality
but I don't subtract an existing future
I don't have to rewrite any code that
was already using this structure and so
this is maybe the idea behind some of
how Python is designed really keep it as
simple as possible from day one
if you're given a requirement try and
get it done by 5:00 p.m. go home spend
time with your family and then wait
until tomorrow when you get a new
requirement to then escalate the
complexity of the code that you've
written and so as we go deeper into this
tutorial we're going to see some
examples where the complexity is indeed
very very very high and there's some
mechanisms that are very sophisticated
and maybe not mechanisms you want to use
from day one there are mechanisms that
you should employ when a requirement
says the only way for you to get this
done with the system that you have
written here is to use this the
sophisticated tool don't use it from day
one because you're just gonna be sitting
writing code all night and you're your
family's gonna be at home just crying
where's I said you said he'd be home at
8:00 p.m. so one thing that I want to
draw your attention to and and maybe one
of the motivations for why we're going
to look into some of the sophistication
is if you look at where we started this
first section of our tutorial with
representing this resistor object is
just a tuple and you look at where we've
ended up representing is a named tuple
there's one little piece that's missing
in the tuple representation we had one
extra field and that extra field was the
type of component that we had and the
reason we might have that extra field is
we might have some code somewhere that
says look at the type and if it's a
resistor do this particular operation
and if it's a capacitor do this other
operation or if it's a resistor then we
know that we know a certain relationship
between the current that passes through
it and the voltage or if it's a
capacitor it's a completely different
relationship and may be nonlinear for
certain circuit elements and when we
turn this into a named tuple we see that
the code slightly changes instead of
directly checking the type we use this
is instance method that's provided to
imply that in the built-ins and
ultimately these two blocks of code do
the same thing they're checking some
they're checking some object and see
what its type is and then they're
dispatching on that type to perform some
operation this isn't even type based
polymorphism this is just very simple
check are you a resistor than do this if
you're a capacitor to do that now one
thing that is very interesting and
meaningful here is notice that the code
at the top and the bottom is now moving
towards using what you might call a
shared vocabulary one of the things that
we can think about for the Python object
model is that it provides us with a
shared vocabulary that forces our code
to maybe integrate
into the Python vernacular into Python
systems as a whole in other words if I
ask you give me an API for figuring out
if a thing is the type of a thing well
one way that you could do is you could
represent those things as tuples and you
could say well there's a field and check
to see if that field is exactly this
string another way you could do is you
could say in Python I'm given a built-in
function and it's called is instance and
that built-in function reads to somebody
reading through that code as asking this
question ours is X a thing of this type
and how I implement that check may be
customizable and in this particular case
it is very customizable we'll see later
how to customize that instance check but
fundamentally what you're looking to do
is you're looking to add a particular
vocabulary employ a particular
vocabulary that is available to you and
made available to you by the built-in
functions and by the objects the the
data model in Python so that your code
reads very closely to the intention of
what you have and so when you read
through this code it reads is less
mechanical or it should read as less
mechanical it should read as asking the
exact intention of what you were trying
to ask are you an instance of this thing
whereas this code here looks a lot more
mechanical Oh is your zero field this
particular field and it doesn't have
that close correspondence between the
intention and the mechanism that's used
to express that intention so let's talk
about the basic object model in Python
what we know about the basic object
model in Python is that we often use it
to implement what we might call
protocols and so you can think for a
very simple Python object like this
resistor class there's some protocol
that represents initialization and
there's some syntax associated with that
and there's some close correspondence
between the syntax that that invokes a
protocol and the way that we go and we
implement that protocol so for example
the syntax here would be this type name
parenthesis syntax that is what we call
initializing and so when we look at this
line we say ok initialize a resistor
with this particular data and we need to
implement what that means for this
resistor type so we write internet
function and the init function is very
simple it just sets fields there's
nothing more complicated than that and
if we do this we can see it works and
it's okay
although the printed representation of
this thing doesn't look very nice at all
kind of ugly and so we might think okay
what's what's missing here what do we
need to implement in order to
prove this printed representation and we
may know that in Python there's a method
called repper it's another method
provided to at the built-ins and it
means give me the human principal
representation of this object and so
what we might think is given that close
correspondence between some built-in
function or some syntax or some TP or
some other bytecode you'll see in a
moment there should be some way to
implement that protocol and in the case
of implementing the built-in repre
function it means implementing the
underscore repper data model method and
so if we go ahead and implement this
data model method then we've satisfied
the ability for this object to get a
human principal representation and you
can see here when I print this out it as
a human principal a human understandable
representation it doesn't tell us just
the type of the object and the objects
ID it tells us information about that
object now if we go to the part of the
Python documentation Doc's top
python.org slash three slash I don't
know just go there and then find it from
there you'll see that actually just
Google for a data model method or for
data model Python you'll see that there
are certain rules around the
implementation of all these protocols
there are certain guidelines what you'll
see often is that these protocols are
rightfully called protocols because
usually what you're doing is you're
taking some fixed mechanism by which you
answer a question or perform some
operation you're hooking into it to add
some small amendment or some small
addendum or some small modification and
then you're dispatching back to that
same protocol on either constituent
object or on base class and so one
example of that is if you go to that
data model page and you look at the
rules around repper one of the rules
that people generally try to abide by
when they're writing the wrapper is that
the thing that this prints out is to be
able to cut and paste and your Python
terminal and when you cut and paste it
you should be able to create an
equivalent object of the same term that
doesn't work because you can see this is
a numeric expression not a string and
this is a variable name not a string so
there's something missing here I need to
put extra quotes around that it may seem
like a very minor thing
oh I'm just missing some quotes I should
just add some extra quotes here and if I
add these extra quotes here
and here then what I get is a repper
that conforms to the standard practice
where if I cut and paste this line right
here and I paste it on my terminal I'll
get another resistor object that should
be equivalent to the first one but what
you might think is well this case it may
not make sense or maybe it might make
sense what if this field here has double
quotes in it maybe that field has single
quotes in it then I have to figure out
how to do that quoting and I have to
come up with some complex some complex
code to figure out how to quote that
thing or to escape quotes and that thing
and instead what I'm missing is that
final piece which is these protocols
almost always dispatch back to the same
protocol and either constituent object
or on a base class and so the answer
here should be something like this the
only real change that I've made is I put
us a bang R at the end of this I put
this field formatting specifier in this
F string and what that means is this is
the equivalent to just calling repper
inside my wrapper these are equivalent
and so the guidance here is that
whenever you're implementing with these
protocols almost always you're going to
call the protocol from within the
protocol and so all you're really doing
in that implementation of that protocol
is just adding your slight modification
and then dispatching back to the
protocol to do the work as expected and
when I finally make this work and I add
an EQ here so that I can actually see
they're equal and I add in I cut and
paste that result then I'll be printed
on this line over here we'll see
everything works as expected and so I
get the resistor printed out nicely if I
cut and paste it at my terminal its back
equal to the original object and so
that's the general guidance that I have
for repper this is why you might this
may answer why for example if you've
opened a file in Python say the file
that we'll look at in a moment network
dot JSON as F and you tried to print out
the wrapper for that thing and you
looked at it you saw it had angle
brackets before and after and some
objects you might see in Python have
those angle brackets before and after he
might wonder why that's in the wrapper
well this is not pilot Python syntax and
so in some cases impossible for that
human principal representation to give
you something that you cut and paste and
get an equivalent version of the same of
the original object in the case of a
file it's because there's going to be a
lot of hidden information here like the
file pointer at the operating system
level or certain buffers that may not be
recreated Belen any fashion or there
could be write buffers that may not be
you may not be able to recreate in any
fashion to reconstitute this and so they
explicitly put these ankle brackets
before and after the repper to indicate
that what I'm showing you is a human
principle representation that could not
ever be reconstituted into the original
object because there's some hidden state
that is impossible for us to capture
it's no longer some kind of immutable or
stateless object like our resistor type
was or some object with some
controllable and visible and manageable
States now it turns out that this stuff
can kind of be a little tricky to get
right because let's say I start with my
resistor and I add in like a variable
resistor like a potentiometer into this
into this problem and my potentiometer
just subclasses from my resistor nothing
too fancy and I create a potentiometer
here and maybe I should call it p4
potentiometer and then I just try and
print it out nothing fancy at all what
you'll see is that the represent right
tells me it's a resistor but it's not
it's a potentiometer and it's just
simply wrong and the reason for that is
you know when I wrote this repper
originally I hard-coded the name of the
type and so maybe I need to do something
fancier I need to dynamically present
the name of the type as part of the
repper by actually looking at the type
at runtime and printing that out now is
this an actual improvement well in this
particular case you can see it prints
this out correctly but this isn't quite
an improvement because it turns out that
this idea of dispatching back to the
underlying protocol doesn't always work
for every protocol in a very nice
fashion it's often the case that you do
have to just go and write the
boilerplate URI implement something and
repairs are very clean a very clear
example of that because if in my
potentiometer class I then add in maybe
the max and the min and the max if you
remember a potentiometer has kind of a
slider on it you kind of slide it there
and it goes between two levels of
resistance and then wherever the slider
is that's the current resistance so
maybe I add in a min and a max resistant
field but then the rest of the fields
are the same as the underlying resistor
so it really is just extending this
underlying resistor class you know I got
to write a new rubber because I have
these extra fields I need to print out
and how does this represent it might be
able to dynamically figure out what the
type of the
like we saw in the previous example but
I'll never be able to figure out to
print out those extra fields as well and
so I'll have to rewrite this and
actually I missed one field here so
we'll add in that extra field so I
should do it like this so there you go
now you might then look at this and say
something doesn't sit right with me
because every time I implement these
protocols I can implement LAN or get
adder or get or get item or call I'm
almost always invariably rien VOC in
that protocol and here I'm not really
doing that
there's just seems to be a lot of
boilerplate with this repper and
unfortunately it's unavoidable because
the only other way you can avoid this is
if you go ahead and try and create your
own protocols or your own object system
and so here's an example of something
that you might try to do you might try
to tell the resistor type here you know
what these are the fields that you have
these are the fields that you have and
along the way we'll also make those
slots because for some reason people
seem to really love talking about slots
even though I think they're just
absolutely boring this can be and so
because I can identify what the fields
are then when I write the wrapper for my
resistor down here I can just have it
dynamically pick out what those fields
are gonna be and print that out and then
that means that any subclass of this
just needs to say oh I'm the
potentiometer I'm just all the resistor
fields plus these two extra fields and I
get that repper for free and what you
can think that you're doing here is
you're kind of creating your own
universe your own set of protocols your
own object model you're creating a set
of guidance or set of rules that every
type in this hierarchy needs to abide by
in order to be consistent because it
could be the case that for example you
subclass something from this a different
type of resistor and you know this is
some some other type of resistor and you
forget to fill in the fields and if you
forget to fill in the fields in the
repertory thing fails and so you might
additional need to add in some guarantee
mechanisms or some mechanism by which
you can enforce from the base class down
to the drive class that you fill out
this object model but fundamentally what
you're what you're seeing is you're
beginning to diverge from what a normal
Python object with the rules of a normal
Python object dictate by adding your own
rules if you create your own subclass
here you also have to fill out these
extra
feel this extra field structure
otherwise you start to potentially lead
to inconsistencies in the way this
operates but for the most part this
works now is this worthwhile is all of
this additional mechanism worthwhile in
this particular case no all you save
yourself is a little bit of boilerplate
then you would have written just just
written once that would have just been a
cut and paste job it's almost certainly
not worthwhile to start adding these
complex object systems on top of the
Python base objects just to save
yourself a job they just give to the
intern right and so there are definitely
cases where you want to build up these
object systems for example if you're
designing a library like an ORM of
course you need to have some kind of
object system and you need to have a
tight set of rules for how people
subclass from your base ORM object but
at something as simple as this no it's
really not worth it and so I think one
of the other guidance is for how to make
best use of the Python object model it's
really don't overthink it sometimes
there is just cut and paste
sometimes there's boilerplate whenever
you're writing your knits there's some
on some necessary amount of boilerplate
there and just live with it just learn
to live with it because trying to get
around it starts getting you into this
deeper and deeper and deeper hole
because for example this object system
has other duplication right these fields
here are repeated here so am I going to
automatically generate the units as well
and what if the anit needs to take some
modality that's not part of the field
and then how do i build into that
abstraction the ability to have these
these additional modalities and this is
going to become more and more and more
complex as it starts to interact with
the real world whereas the cut and paste
approach would give you that infinite
flexibility where oh this particular
subclass needs to have an extra flag and
that flag is not a field it's just some
modality flag for guiding the rest like
the units in which the resistance are in
and then you can see that just
everything will fall apart and so it
really it really you really have to be
judicious about using that now if you
really wanted to be clever
you could try you could really try very
hard to use some of pythons
introspective nature in order to get
around not building your own object
system but fundamentally you're
basically doing the same thing and so in
this example here instead of identifying
what the fields are I use the inspect
module signature to look at the
signature of the init
to figure out from the signature of the
anit what the fields would be and then
to automatically generate the wrapper
from that and so the magic line here is
just this line here which figure out
what figures out what the fields are and
then automatically Princeton so you see
both of these representation where if
there were some modality here this
modality would be interpreted as a field
not a mode and I'd have to figure I'd
have to say here oh look at all the look
at all of the parameters to this init
function that happened to not be keyword
our only arguments or whatnot or you'd
have to get people to say you know this
is a read-only field that have to use
annotations or some nonsense like that
and it's you're just you're just adding
a lot of complexity for what is really
just a little bit of boilerplate that
you just have to suck up the right now
all of this kind of discussion of an
object system or crating Onuaku system
should remind you of something else that
you've seen in the Python standard
library Python 3.7 and we got the
ability to or we got in the standard
library our own version of tools that
have existed outside the standard
library for some time which is automatic
generation of the boilerplate for a
class and the standard libraries they're
called data classes and these are
immutable types that automatically
generate a repper and in it for you
you use the variable annotations that
were added in Python 3.7 I believe in
order to specify information that's
never actually used anywhere so don't
think that this is actually checking
that these are strings in a float no it
doesn't actually do that but maybe your
maybe your type hinting tool does that I
don't know I don't use those I don't
think they're that useful either but you
get a lot of a lot of a lot of code for
free and so from our perspective of
doing the least amount of work in order
to implement the system I think there's
something worthwhile here and I am
personally a big fan of data class
although I would say you know it doesn't
really matter what you put there unless
you're really using the type ending
stuff although maybe if you're to extend
data classes yourself to add your own
mechanisms you might put something here
that might be more interesting like some
automatic validator or initializer
something better than the pepp 44 type
int Inc
stuff because I mean the the variable
annotation just gives you some structure
place to put some information which you
could then retrieve as part of your
object system now one of the things I
want to draw your attention to is that
as we can see and as we saw in the
previous example as we get deeper into
the Python object modeling we implement
all these underscore functions we're
effectively creating a vocabulary that
describes how our objects interact and
how we interact with those objects and
so in this case we have some network of
circuit elements and they and we can ask
that network how big are you like how
many elements that you have what would
that what would that mean how many
elements you have how many connections
you have how many nodes you have but
there's some particular meaning that you
might you might assume when somebody
asks how big is this network and the way
that you might implement that is by
using Len Len is a very natural way in
Python to express trying to figure out
how big this thing is
and then you implement it with your
underscore Len or you might need to
retrieve something from this network for
example you might need to retrieve one
of the elements by it's part number and
you can think this idea of retrieving
something corresponds in Python to the
square bracket syntax and so you to
implement get item and this would be
better than writing your own you know
get part by number function or your own
get size function because what you're
thinking is that the thinking behind
this is by sticking close to the
vocabulary provided to you by the
built-in functions and a Python based
data model what what you're doing is
you're reusing a vocabulary that already
exists that describes the way that
Python objects that people are very
familiar with interact you're
encouraging the objects that you create
to better integrate with the core
language itself you're encouraging the
code that you write to minimize the
additional entities that somebody needs
to understand in order to understand the
code that you wrote and so I would say
that implementing Len might be a net
benefit over writing a getsize even
though you might say this is more
explicit this is something where
somebody looks a Python programmer looks
at Len on an object and they intuitively
think this is saying what's the size of
this thing
and as long as this network has one
unique privileged notion of its size in
this case we're assuming that that would
be the number of elements then this this
produces code that's
that integrates nicely into existing
Python code and that minimizes the
amount of additional API documentation
we have to have because you can think
here if you had a get size you'd have to
write some API documentation and I
suspect that the API documentation right
for Len would be much smaller Len would
just be give the size of Network in
elements whereas here you might need to
add additional qualifications now
unfortunately one of the downsides is
it's not always clear where this or how
this vocabulary is specified or what the
terms in this vocabulary mean unless
you've been using Python for a very long
time and there may be cases where you
look at how Python works and you might
assume that there's a vocabulary in
place when there really isn't and one
example that I ran into a very long time
ago was the hash method in Python we
know there's a built-in function called
hash and Python and if we look at that
where you could say oh this gives us
some unique identifier for an object
that might represent this object in a
fixed space and a fixed integer space
and so I might then use that if I need
to store my objects in my own custom
object database or store them in some
fashion that needs to be retrieved off
of disk I might say well I need to find
some way to compute this hash you know
what I'll just use the built-in hash
protocol I'll use the built-in hash
function and the underscore hash method
and that's how I'll make it work but
unfortunately that's not what hash means
in Python hash means something much
narrower in Python it means give me a
single integer that can then be used to
compute what the array index for how
this thing will be stored in a set or a
dictionary because for example if you
have a Python object and it's hash
always returns negative 1 it does not
always return negative 1 it is
impossible in C python for the hash of
an object to be any to be negative 1
always it scores to a negative 2 why
because deep in the bowels of c python
this negative 1 value is used as a c
value to indicate that there was an
error in the computation of the hash so
every time a hash every time i
underscore hash method returns negative
1 it gets coerced to a negative 2
there's a line of code there where it
says if it's negative 1 return negative
2 and so you can think why does this
make sense because it doesn't happen pi
pi doesn't happen in any alternative
python at any non c python
implementation well it's because this
protocol does not mean oh just compute a
hash they could be used in many
different places and could be used in or
to store this an object database or
stored on disk this means very
specifically and very narrowly compute
something that will be used by the
Python interpreter itself for the
purposes of that running instance of
that Python interpreter and no more and
sometimes that small and very subtle
distinction may not be visible when
you're reading through the documentation
or reading through Python code for the
most part these these corner cases are
fairly rare but there are these corner
cases where you look at something you
say oh this is a nice way to express an
idea using the built-in using the Python
data model and it's not because there's
some nuance there for example if you
look a little bit deeper
hache may also in some cases add some
randomization factor in order to avoid
DDoS attempts for Python systems that
are built to have some kind of user
exposure and so what the actual hashed
value that's produced by this method may
not always be predictable and it may
change between different invitations are
the same interpreter with the same
version of Python and the same code
based on the same machine and so it's
not something that you can reliably use
it can use to compute something and so
in this case it would actually be the
case that if you wanted to have your
objects serializable into your own
object dictionary and they need to have
some unique identifier in that sorry in
that object store then you might
actually have to write your own hash
without the underscores function and you
might have to now duplicate the entities
because this object here might then have
both a hash of something well just do
and may have both this and its own hash
method and this may seem unnecessarily
macey unnecessarily redundant but this
one is being used for internal use by
the Python interpreter in this one's
being used for some kind of external
protocol and so being able to
distinguish what these protocols are
whether they're actually for broad used
to describe the interactions in your
object or they're just used for hooking
into the Python runtime can sometimes be
a little bit tricky to see although I
can tell you that there's fairly few
circumstances where this occurs most of
the time you can reuse these protocols
to express whatever meaning you want an
example of that would be and you this
made this may make some of you think of
the path Lib module and Python
and one of the things that people like
about the path Lib module is that it
gives you controllable programmatic
access to pads like you can switch out
suffixes and get parent paths you can
resolve them
you get relative paths and absolute
paths so trying to do string
manipulation so what you do is you put
that string into some structured you put
that string data into some structured
object that object then gives you
structured ways to manipulate it but
other people like it because you can use
the solidus you can use the slash to
mean the same thing as like you know
directory slash directory and this is
this this I think was controversial
because I think a lot of people really
objected to the use of what appears to
be a mathematical operator to just kind
of do some cute syntax and you can
really go as far as you want with this
and so here's a stupid example of using
map mole the app sign to automatically
generate emails this is absolutely
pointless this is not an arithmetic
operation all of the assumptions that
you might bring to mat Mall like for
example it performs some non
element-wise operation you know it may
not be it may not be associated or may
not be commutative those all break this
is just gimmicky syntax and some people
seem to like that I don't know I think
you can go a little bit too far so this
is an example of going way too far now
that said path Lib force up for whatever
reason people seem to like so you can't
you can't complain too much now let me
let me dive a little bit deeper into
maybe some of the motivation behind all
of this because I think that sometimes
looking at some of these mechanics might
be overwhelming and so I want to give
you a case study a real-world or
simplified example of a real-world case
study of where some of these mechanisms
are valuable and one of the one of the
thought processes you can have by for
when you might use some of the
mechanisms especially some of the more
sophisticated mechanisms were about to
look at is to think about how use of the
Python object model not only can give
you this common vocabulary to describe
inner relations between your objects but
it can also give you the ability to
rearrange the complexity of your program
to serve certain human needs
so give an example let's say that we
have a simple report and that report has
some information before and after so
we've actually done the circuit analysis
and we figured out where the currents
are and we can see given some layout of
the circuit some
dialling on that potentiometer the
currents are where they were in the
before line and then after we dial that
potentiometer differently the currents
are there and for some reason in this
particular example one of the currents
dropped out the other one dropped in so
maybe we dialed one of the potentiometer
so that it became so that there was no
longer like a span between those two
nodes and one of the things we might
want to do is we want to actually
compare like what's the before in the
after so we might want to generate a
simple report I'm gonna generate a
simple report that looks like this these
are the four currents these are the
after currents this is the absolute
Delta and that's the percentage Delta
and it turns out that in many fields
this report was actually something that
I spent quite a bit of time doing when I
was when I was building PNL systems for
front office trading desks because
there's often the case that we'd have to
do is you'd have to come out with a new
financial model for a bond and you'd
have to see how that model compared
against the old model so you might price
this over a set of days and look at the
differences and one of the common things
that when you generate a report like
this somebody asks for is they want to
be able to flag things that are severely
out of variance because if you look at
the differences here you can see for
current one
it went from ten I guess amps to 14 amps
that's a meaningful change current to
went from 15 to 14 that could have been
you know if we were using some kind of
kickoffs Laplace you know inverse matrix
formulation this could have been some
kind of rounding errors so that might
not even be worthwhile to look at and
then here you can see this current 5
went from 1 to 50 so clearly something
went really wild with resistance on that
span because we increase the we increase
the current by you know five thousand
percent and so how might we want to look
at that well in the confines of a very
simple text report maybe we'll just add
a little star to the end of the lines
well at the end of the lines add a
little star we'll add a little flag so
we'll say you know looking at the
percent difference if it's greater than
50 percent at a star star if it's
greater than 10 percent a little star
and as simple it can be if you look at a
report now we can see we stored that and
that as being very meaningful things to
look at it's a very common thing to do
imagine if you're comparing two runs of
a model and you need to figure out where
were the meaningful changes from day 1
to day 2 or the meaningful changes
before and after we made a change now
the question is is it likely that this
functionality here when you're
constructing that flag is it likely that
might appear in different
places within your system of course
because the guidance for how generate
this flag might be something that is
necessary not only in this particular
report but at any other subsequent
report that you do maybe you have some
model and you're looking at its
performance its memory use I'm sorry or
maybe even you're looking at its
predictive capabilities and this
flagging there's percentage flag and
something you want to use in all three
places and so instead of cutting and
pasting these five lines of code you
need to find some abstraction allows you
to reuse the same flagging mechanism
same percent flagging mechanism in three
places
now as a you know data scientists whose
may be mostly familiar with writing
functions or mostly comfortable writing
functions you might say this is a
perfect example of refactoring just
extract this to a function so I have a
simple function called get flag I give
it the percentage difference it looks at
the percentage difference and it gives
me that flag and I generate my report
from that and everything works as I
expected and now in the different parts
of my system where I need to use that
flag
I just reused this function this is very
basic modularity right but I want to
suggest you maybe a different approach
to take and a different approach to take
that might comport a little bit better
with what we've been looking at so far
about building this common vocabulary
but also about how we can rearrange the
complexity of a program using this
Python object system and so as an aside
I have a small question for you we know
that there exist many protocols in
Python like get adder get item and call
get I get adders for looking up an
attribute by dotted name syntax get item
is by looking at something with square
brackets and call is whenever you invoke
something with the parentheses after it
what is the difference between these
three clearly there's a difference
between get adder and the other two
because the argument for get adder is
always a string with maybe underscores
in it but you can never really implement
get item with get adder that's
impossible
but what's other ways we can get item
and call like why does it matter if I
chose in my protocol to use square
brackets here are parentheses you might
say what it conveys to the reader of
this code may be different in this case
you're conveying look something up in
this case you're conveying compute
something but mechanically there really
is no difference the code here is the
same the protocol is different the
syntax is different but it may not be
clear where that difference is
now putting that aside let's rearrange
the complexity in this original example
instead of having a function that gets
to flag let's create a structure and
we'll call it a range dictionary and
just like a normal dictionary it'll look
things up but unlike a normal dictionary
it won't look things up exactly it'll
look things up belong to some range so
if the value that it's looking up is
between the range of 0 and 10% they'll
give me just an empty string 10% to 50%
will give me a single star 50% to
infinity will give me a double store and
then all amend my report so in my report
I just look up the flag using this
lookup and that kind of makes sense
because we know that square bracket kind
of means look something up so this means
in this very last line of my report look
up the flag given the percent difference
and we could see there's a very close
correspondence with what we originally
wrote which used a function formulation
and we're writing here which is using
some kind of look up some getitem
formulation now the actual mechanism
that we might employ to to make this
work might look something like this
we'll have ranged X sub class from a
dict it'll implement part of the object
make part of the dictionary protocol
called missing when you look for a key
that doesn't exist you invoke this this
is a very inefficient implementation
because it's a linear search through the
ranges but you can imagine that you
could recode this as a more efficient
maybe logarithmic search through the
ranges and you could also even add some
logic up here that make sure the ranges
are not overlapping and that there's no
gaps between them but fundamentally
beyond all of those mechanics and I'll
hide this mechanics here once you think
about how this is different than the
first example here if we compare these
two and the first example you have a
function called get flag we have one
function called get flag that tries to
figure out what the flag should be and
in the latter example we have a piece of
data that indicates the flags and a type
and you can see there's the same
fundamental complexity in both of them
there in fact the same operation exists
in both of them if we wanted to make the
first one generic and the same way this
is we could pass in the ranges as a as a
piece of code as a some input data and
we'd have some code that looks like this
inside of that function to figure out
are you within the ranges or not but
fundamentally what's the difference here
well I think what you can see is that
what we've done is we've taken that
fixed amount of complexity and we've
moved it into two places we've moved the
complexity for the lookup mechanism in
the type we move the complexity for the
data that feeds that lookup mechanism
into the data here and so we've taken
that complexity we display data part now
is that beneficial or not well this is a
lot more sophisticated in terms of the
the use of Python than the first example
but what you could think is if these
ranges were to change later be a lot
safer to change it here and we detect in
the first one if you wanted to make sure
that this was done correctly not
programmatically but just by you know
eyeballing it it's probably a lot easier
to eyeball it here than the first
version and so you can see that when you
can rearrange the complexity in your
program in the right way you might
facilitate certain human actions like
refactoring maintenance or the
confidence of correctness maybe not
automatic or verified correctness but
just human understandability of the code
in different ways now all of that should
remind you of something else from the
Python standard library
you know our chain map and our chain map
is a perfect example of this it's often
the case and the problems that we solve
we have some mechanism that we see
somewhere that looks kind of like layers
or scopes or something like that there's
some look up and there's some way to add
some layer in front of that lookup to
modify that lookup and that's exactly
what the chain map is it's a data type
that gives you this just chained lookup
and so in the chain map you might have
two resistors and this may be part of
some simulation example you're trying to
do for example you might have the
resistance of the of the network
supplied by the chain up and then when
you want to test something you might
push into this chain map a new value for
the first resistor and when you're done
testing you might just delete it off the
front and what you can see when you run
this example is you know the value of
this resistor goes from ten to fifteen
to ten because the chain map is just a
ordered look up through these different
Maps and the first map that finds it in
it it returns that value now you might
dislike this because you can say you
know some of this list manipulation
isn't Dell and insert it's probably not
particularly efficient we're always told
to try and avoid those structures if you
want to you can always be cute in Python
people might advise you not to be cute
but you should be who you are and so you
could always swap out the maps and the
chain map for the deck and now you have
very high efficiency insertion or
removal from either side of the chain
map and so now you can write a very
high-performance kind of
almost sort of like a copy-on-write or a
cheap view mechanism on this underlying
data now you probably might not want to
use the chain app directly but you can
think if you lift that up into your own
custom type then you can have your
custom type have this very nice
automatic you know undo behavior without
having to employ a very sophisticated
mechanism taking the sophistication of
how that undo works and isolating in the
type itself and using something from the
standard library to that there are some
severe limitations to this approach to
writing Python one of the questions I
asked you before was what's the
difference between get a target item and
Paul and get adder is very very clearly
different from the other to get item and
call may be very similar here's an
example of three things and I'm curious
what the difference is between these
three unnamed function get item and call
and I can do the same thing it's the
syntax is very very slightly different I
switch between parentheses to square
brackets to a dotted name lookup and
then parentheses very slight differences
here what's the fundamental difference
which one do I choose I'm told that
maybe I should choose one of these two
because this adds unnecessary entities
for somebody who's reading my code to
try to understand so they have to look
up what this means whereas here there
may be some certain assumptions that if
you correctly abide by somebody can read
that code and not have to just take the
assumptions that pop into their head and
continue understanding what the code
does in a very high level before they
have to dig into the documentation
whereas every time you have a dotted
function somebody's going to really feel
like despite what it might what its name
might be I really need to look at the
docs for that and so maybe that's one
guidance but that's a human guidance is
there any technical distinction between
these three it turns out that there are
there are some significant ones first
what if you need to pass two arguments
in you can't do that with getitem game
takes literally one argument it's just a
thing to look up right whereas call can
take as many arguments as you want now
you might say well that's not such a big
deal because if I pass in two arguments
I'll pass them in using the same syntax
but it'll be passed in as a tuple and
I'll just de structure that tuple there
that's a little hokey but where this
really breaks is what if it what if you
need to use keyword arguments there's no
possible way to add keyword arguments in
this structure and
you start mimicking like JavaScript you
know passing objects to functions
there's no other way to add keyword
Artemis here with the nice syntax
whereas with your call there's a way to
do keyword argit's and so what I said
originally was oftentimes which you
might do in Python is you might start
with the simplest implementation and
then increase the complexity is the
complexity of the problem we're trying
to solve increases when you're choosing
how to implement the parts of the data
model that may not always be the case
because sometimes you can code yourself
into a corner for example imagine that
this type here represented some kind of
object database some storage and you
wanted to use the square bracket lookup
to pull some object out of that database
by a path but then you need to add a
modality to that you know are you
running against the production database
for this database or you're doing a dry
run versus a non dry run or are you
doing a verbose or non verbose you
immediately are no longer able to use
the square bracket syntax because it can
no longer accommodate that keyword
argument modality and so you have to
drop back into using maybe the call
protocol and you'll have to go and we
write a lot of code and so sometimes
being very judicious about how you pick
which protocol that you implement may be
important because switching between
these is harder than you might expect in
certain cases or they may or there may
be sufficient technical requirements
that force you into one of these versus
the other now you might say well as a
precaution I'll always only use calling
whenever use square brackets energies
get item but that may not be that may
not be a wise or judicious move because
there may be cases where this get item
really is the most natural way to look
at it but you really have to keep at the
forefront of your mind
what are the limitations that I'm buying
into there's another also very serious
and severe limitation here that we
haven't talked about at all but we've
hinted at slightly and I want to talk
about one thing that you may have seen
and you may have wondered about which is
a class method and often times when
people talk about the object model they
kind of think about the object model
less well there's a bunch of underscore
methods there's properties they're
static methods and there's class methods
and that's about it and they say they
might talk about class method as oh it
doesn't take an instance it takes a
class and static method doesn't take any
arguments and that may be as deep as
they go but instead I want to guide your
you through a different way to think
about some of these things and one of
the other serious limitations of how you
choose to use a Python object model to
implement this common vocabulary
here I have a simple Network that's
initialized with a set of resistors and
it just stores that information it
doesn't do anything interesting with it
right what if this data came from a file
should I write my in it like this maybe
it takes a filename and if you provide
the file name then you open up that file
and you read the resistors from that and
it's a very common thing I might not
always want to instantiate this object
from data that exists written out in my
program I want to give it a file and
have it figure out how to read and parse
that file and do something with it and
so you might say oh that's not so bad
it's a little bit clumsy because I'm not
sure what I do if I provide both this
argument in this argument but it's not
so bad don't do this one of the
guidances that is not explicate 'add in
the data model documentation for python
is guidance around what an it should
look like and as I told you previously
sometimes it's not worth creating your
own object systems your own kind of
pseudo versions of data classes data
class in order to avoid writing
boilerplate and one of the two or the
two common boilerplates that you might
want to avoid writing or repper
and in it my guidance for you is this
init is always and should always be
boilerplate and it's just boilerplate
and just leave it a boilerplate your NIT
should almost never do anything fancier
than setting attributes checking that
you're constructing a valid object or
constructing derived information you'll
see an example later where we construct
some derived information like we take
the connections of a network coming in
for maybe what the elements are but here
doing something like reading from a file
is a terrible idea
you know why what format is this file in
it's at an XML file ok great I have the
data in CSV format what do I do now am I
going to pass in an argument called file
name equals this and I'm gonna say if
file iam is not none if and I'll use
path Lib file name dot suffix equals
Excel do something here
otherwise if it's something else
do something here no this is gonna be
atrocious right and certainly I do not
want to do maybe it doesn't come from
just a file name maybe it comes from a
file name or from a database do I want
to pass extra arguments and I have all
these different ways to construct it and
all them at the
modalities Mayan it explode and
fundamentally if I construct different
flower name the replicate how it got
constructed and then you're gonna find
that round tripping of the repper to the
unit it's gonna be very difficult to
make it consistent fundamentally what
you can also think is here this is one
of the serious limitations that you have
to keep in mind when you're designing
objects in Python the protocol methods
give you a common vocabulary for how to
describe the interrelations between your
objects assuming that for that each for
each element to that vocabulary there is
one privileged unique meaning for that
so in the previous example we talked
about a network and we talked about
using len to figure out what the size of
the network was is there only one
meaning for the size of the network well
maybe maybe not maybe in our use case
the only one meaning is the number of
elements but another use case if we were
for example doing some kind of mesh
analysis maybe it's the number of meshes
maybe we need to surface both use cases
both the number of meshes number of
loops that we're going to compute so
that's the number of rows in our laplace
matrix that will actually have to
compute the voltage in the current on
the matrix on or the of the network on
and maybe also the elements because we
have some production need to say okay
this thing passed past some verification
step and go and go through these
elements this is how many elements
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to purchase in order to produce this
know if there are two meanings which
gets to use the underlying protocol
method you can see this problem here
here we're saying there's many ways to
initialize this object you can
initialize from the actual data or from
a file or from a database or from
something else
which ones that one true right way to do
it and if there is no one true White Way
one unique privileged way to implement
that VOC at that piece of vocabulary to
call and you should not use a protocol
at all because you're going to end up
confusing somebody because they're going
to call Len and the result they're gonna
get is not going to comport with their
assumption for what you meant by the
size is such a similarly here this an it
the arguments that you passed which to
comport what somebody's understanding
for how to initializes now an it is
special in the case that an object must
have internet whereas an object doesn't
necessarily have to have any of the
other pieces of the protocol
of the data model and so the guidance
there should be to always have the
unique singular meaning for your for
your objects for the initialization of
your objects to just be initialized them
with the raw underlying data and do a
bunch of boilerplate to set this object
up and don't do anything interesting
don't do any stateful actions don't read
a file don't read from the database
don't do any of that that should be the
answer and what you should instead do is
use class methods think about what class
method does it gives you and it gives
you a class from which you can derive
whatever you want and so what you could
think is all the different ways to
construct this object that are not
constructing it from the raw data itself
can be a class because class methods are
not singular and privileged you can have
as many class methods as you want if you
want to construct this from my file you
can use a class method called from file
if you want to construct it from an
excel file you could use one call from
excel file and these can be duplicated
as you desire and so a class method is
not only this idea that you have some
method that gives you a class and you
can from that construct an instance but
also the idea that this is a mechanism
by which you can add to a class
protocols that are not unique and
privileged but instead might be
duplicated in order to satisfy a variety
of use cases when there's not one
privileged way to for example construct
an object and so that's the general
guidance for where class methods tend to
be used what what you might call factory
functions and the reason why they're
used in that fashion and you should
never use internet is we no longer have
one privilege the way to construct this
object but instead we have multiple
possible ways to construct it now with
that said let's dive a little bit deeper
into the object model and I'll touch
upon a couple of small things that you
might be interested in or might be might
be useful to you to know here we have
our named tuple representation of the
resistor and nothing too fancy there now
when we look at this example here
we can see whoops let's do this one
first we can see that there's a problem
and the data we've passed you pass a
negative resistance which for the
purposes of example shouldn't really
exist these resistors should always be
positive now it may be the case that in
our program that's not an error that
anybody makes and so maybe we don't need
to do anything about it
maybe this is something that could just
as simply be caught by code review but
if it were the case that it was not
something that could be simply caught by
code review or there might be some
additional value to catching it ahead of
time then we may need some mechanism by
which we try to catch that error now one
of the things we could try to do is we
could try to take the name tuple
subclass from it and implement new and
in this new we could check to see if the
resistance was negative and if it was
than to provide an error message and to
say oh it's got to be a positive number
you gave me a negative resistance and
then that gives us some better guidance
but the thing is if it's a named tuple
this thing is immutable so that's a fair
thing to do but if we need this
resistance to be mutable for example if
that potentiometer where we might dial
it back and forth to change the
resistance and it has to just be between
the min and the max value then it very
well need to be the case that we need to
change the resistance later and here in
this case we can't change the reason
because this thing is a it's a subclass
of a tuple it's immutable but if this
were a rich object and we needed to be
able to change this then we need to
figure out some way to do that now if
you're a Java programmers circa Java
like 2015 maybe we might write getters
and setters we might say in order to
prevent this update anomaly or in order
to prevent this anomaly whereby we
change this field to it to an invalid
value we're going to force you to go
through this getter in the center to
interact with the underlying data on
this on this class and so here this
check that we put up here might also be
duplicated down here and we do
fundamentally get the ability to check
that if you set the resistance on this
thing if you mutate this thing and set
the resistance that it's
no there's a this would be value that
it's it's indeed positive now the
problem here is that how do we choose
when to write our getters and setters in
fact we may decide that every field
always needs navigator in center because
there could always be some need later
down the line to add validation how do
we know ahead of time that this is the
validation we need and we're told as a
guidance that we should never write code
that hasn't been explicitly asked for us
because it's just going to draw just
gonna add more lines of code that we
don't have to refactor later as a
business problem changes and so there's
something missing from here now what you
might already know the answer is is that
this is why the property pattern exists
in Python this is why the property
decorator exists the property decorator
gives you the ability to add in hooks
into the lookup or setting of an
attribute after the class has already
been constructed and already been used
and so here in this example I just use
property and then when you try and pull
out the resistance you pull out this
field that has been demarcated as being
private in this instance when you're
trying to set it we put the check here
and then the code works now the guidance
here is that not just that this is
something that we didn't need to have
from day one in fact our first version
of this code might very well just look
like this right just very well look just
like that and doesn't do any checks
whatsoever and maybe there's a bug there
but maybe if that bug is not common
enough it's not does it warrant the
effort for those extra seven lines of
code and that's fine and then when we
discover that there is a requirement we
can add in these two checks here it'll
start to catch invalid code more
aggressively but the rest of the code
that we wrote for this no longer changes
the API doesn't change so we don't have
to go from having a raw attribute to a
setter and a getter however another
thing that I would like you to think
about from this is that what is the
difference between a property and a
named function they both can compute
something right like there's both space
here and here to compute something so
what's the difference between this and
this well clearly you can't fit
arguments into the property right so the
property can operate on the state of the
class but there's no way to fit in
either
or keyword arguments so just like the
difference you can get item and call you
can see there's a functional is a
there's a formal difference between
these two
there's also another difference which is
typically when somebody looks at a
property they don't expect there to be a
computation that's very time-consuming
or that has stateful effect whereas with
a call there's usually a free assumption
for something that might have stateful
effect now as we said before why not
just always use this this syntax what I
always use call it's the least
restricted one of the other principles I
think of Python is you'll often find in
Python that there are do a letís there
are structures that are more flexible in
structures that are less flexible or
more constrained a very simple example
is you have your def formulation for for
writing a function you have a lambda why
bother to use lambda yeah it saves a
couple of lines of code but you can only
have one line you can't have any you
can't have any statements in it can only
be expressions why have list
comprehensions when you can just build
the list with the for loop well the
reason is oftentimes in your reading
through code if somebody makes a choice
of using a more restricted structure
then it helps the reader because their
guests work for what actually happens
behind the scenes in order for them to
kind of pierce the veil of that
abstraction is less and so one of the
reasons why you might choose to use a
more restricted a more restricted part
of the data model is not only because
you forecast that you don't need keyword
arguments or some additional
functionality but you're also subtly
broadcasting to the reader that this
thing only does so much and only can do
so much and only will ever be designed
to do so much and so in the case of
property here you're saying this is
something that doesn't need to know any
information other than the current state
of the object whereas call could need
much more information that gets passed
in and you may not always be clear about
what's gets passing because it could
have like a star star kwargs argument
there and there could be fields or that
are that are passed and parameters
they're passing they're not ex placated
in the doc string more fundamentally
however this guides us to some
information about something kind of
interesting which is there is part of
the Python object model about how do you
look up properties and so I wanted to do
a deep dive into in the remaining 13
minutes we have I want to do a deep dive
into two parts of the Python object
model to show you how much flexibility
there is
fundamentally what I want you to think
about here is that python is not is not
fundamentally dynamic it's more
operationally dynamic in the sense that
somebody has built a model they've added
hook points specific parts you can hook
into those hook points but there are
going to be gaps whereby there's just
not a way to hook into this behavior or
there's a corner case or there's a wart
and so you'll see that even with get add
or get attribute and get you may already
be familiar with get adder we've seen it
before this is what gets hooked when you
do attribute look like ABC right and so
you can see here this get adder just
takes what it's looking up and gives you
the string back upper case very simple
now you might also be familiar that if
this attribute already exists then get
out or doesn't get called so you can see
get adder didn't get called so you may
be familiar that as part of that object
lookup protocol there's actually also a
get attribute that gets triggered before
you actually check to see if that
actually existed or not and so if you
switch this from get adder to get
attribute suddenly that call is
intercepted and so what you can think
here is that there's some protocol
there's some steps for how you retrieve
an attribute from an object and you go
through those steps and in each step
somebody is denotative these are hook
points one of them is before you even
look it up call get attribute then look
it up normally if it exists there return
it otherwise call get out and even
things like property fit into that
because things like property implemented
using another protocol called the
descriptor protocol what happens is when
you look something up in an object if
you don't see it on the instance and you
don't get it back from get ederoar from
get attribute but you find it on the
class and the thing that you find on the
class has a get method then you call
that kept method so you have yet another
hook point and this is how class method
static method actually no that's not a
static method it works but it's how
class method normal methods and or all
Python functions actually but class
method normal methods and property are
implemented using this descriptive
protocol and so it's just get another
hook point now the reason to go through
these and the reason to go through is
quite quickly is that knowing exactly
the details of how this protocol works
is less important than knowing the
protocol exists and knowing that when
you're asking a Python object to give
you an attribute there just tend to be
certain hook points in that and having a
broad awareness those hook points exist
as part of the design of your system the
details of those hook points are
multifaceted like what is this instance
an owner quite mean and what can we use
to employ that there's quite a lot of
detail there but it's not necessary to
know that at a very high level what's
probably most important for most of you
to understand as you set out to design
production systems is that this exists
at all and how it's designed and
structured similarly I want to talk
about the object construction protocol
we know that we can construct an object
by class T and then there's an object
but this is actually dynamic code this
doesn't this isn't C++ this isn't C this
isn't Java there isn't some bag of bits
that represent this class or in C++ and
C no actual runtime representation of
this class but only some compile time
representation to figure out how you can
translate pointer accesses into you know
direct offset you know load operations
this is actually runtime code and we may
be familiar that there's a disk module
in Python and that this module
disassembles code so I have a simple
piece of code like X plus y and it
disassemble it I can see the Python
bytecode a very brief introduction to it
this is the line number this is the
offset for the bytecode this is the
bytecode this is the operand this is the
interpretation of the operand you can
see when we add two values we just call
a binary add and that's how this is how
Python works underneath the covers it's
running through these byte codes it's
running these byte codes it sees the
binary atom then it dispatches to pi PI
number ad or PI object ad or whatever
one of those methods to go and figure
out what this what this addition
operation actually does in fact in the
case of binary ad it'll first check to
see if that's if they're both Unicode
types and then I'll perform a sequence
concatenation as a fast path and
otherwise they'll dispatch to the
numeric addition mechanisms which will
then dispatch to on an American dition
or concatenation operations now one
interesting thing that you might see is
if you try and create a class inside a
function you disassemble that you look
at that you can see this thing called
load build class now if we're running
Python 2 which i really suggest most of
you do because it's going away soon so
you might as well get just your last few
minutes of Python 2 in it's actually
even easier to see in Python 2 you see
there's a there's a bytecode called
build class and one of the
correspondences that we saw very early
in this talk was a correspondence
between some built-in function sum
underscore method that implements that
built-in function as part of the
vocabulary
other correspondence for every one of
these bike coats there's usually or for
many of these bike coasters a
correspondence between this and some
mechanism that implements that and so it
turns out there's a mechanism that
implements how a class is built in
Python there is in fact a built-in
function in the built-ins called build
class and if you write your own version
of it you hook every class construction
and the entire runtime of your program
and so here if we run this block of code
we'll see when we built this class teeth
we hooked into this code here and we got
the function that would create T in the
name of T now there's not a mechanism
that you're commonly that you might be
aware of in part because it is not a
surgical mechanism it is a incredibly
broad broad sort and as a consequent is
not particularly useful for anything
production it's not used for any sort of
business logic I'll show you why let's
say we hooked into build class to hook
into when classes were constructed and
then we just very innocently import a
JSON module and data classes module this
hooks into every class construction in
your running program and so it hooks
into a bunch of stuff and there's very
low likelihood you want to hook it on to
loop that's all those so this build
class mechanism is is there and it
exists and what it might be useful for
is if for example you need to modify
certain things like memory allocation or
you want to do some debugging you want
to see what classes were constructed you
wanted to see you wanted to notate where
classes are constructed when and why you
wanted to do some kind of logging or
some kind of automated testing for
example every time a class is run maybe
you run some tests associated with it
and under some certain debug mode
something like that but other than that
it's not particularly useful more useful
might be the metaclass mechanism now we
don't have enough time to talk about
what amount of class truly is and I gave
a talk about two years ago called how to
be a Python Bob Loblaw expert blah blah
blah and it got a lot of hits on YouTube
because the title was just provocative
enough that people wanted to click on it
to either put you down and say oh that's
so easy that's not Python expertise or
they were genuinely student learning
about it but I would suggest you might
look up that talk if you're interested
when I'm at a class truly is so our
perspective here we'll just talk about a
meta class in terms of the mechanism
that it provides it's just a hook into
the object construction process in other
words when you construct the type here
and you give it a meta class there
two hook points for how that type is
constructed once called new and one
coordinate is actually one more called
call when go into that here and they
just hook points for when this object is
constructed so if we run this code we
can see as we constructed this T we got
hooks into them and because we have a
hook into the construction of this T we
can do things like modify this we can
add extra fields we do some fancy things
one one fancy thing we might be able to
do is we might be able to supply the
dictionary that's used for processing
the body of that class and so here this
prepare which was actually also
available in Python 2 gives you the
ability to hook into the dictionary
that's provided for as a namespace for
the constructor in the by this class
which may seem very abstract but you
almost certainly seen something like
this before
that's how enum works in the standard
library this auto think look what does
it do well what's happening is in the
enum enum has a meta class which it's
inherited so this components inherits
that meta class when you inherit that
meta class and you process this code
you're given a dictionary when that
dictionary is filled up actually that's
not actually don't tell that exactly how
it you know works but as a dictionary is
filled up you can do whatever magics you
want one of the things that is necessary
is in Python 2 you have to provide an
ordered dictionary cuz python 2
dictionaries are long are ordered so you
do have to use prepare that gives you
these in ordered and then you can use
the new or the in it on the metaclass in
order to swap out these auto fields with
an actual numerical constant in Python 3
you just can use auto but in Python 2
that's not possible because I didn't add
auto to the enum type but it really only
about looks like this in Python as I
said you just provide an order dict when
you're providing the namespace for
executing this class as you execute this
class you just look for all the items
that are auto and if they're auto items
then you replace them with a numerical
value this is how you can implement this
about 15 lines of code to implement some
fairly sophisticated functionality now
again there's quite a few details here
and this is also Python 2 code so you
know get your last bits of Python to it
before it goes away but fundamentally
what's important to understand is that
as part of these as part of building
this universe in Python there are a lot
of these hook points in both get
attribute lookup or act or object
construction that give you the ability
to customize how Python does these
operations you might take for granted
and so the combination of all of these
together or what gives you your own
custom object system this is how most
large production systems end up looking
like I don't think we'll have time to go
over the example but in the example I'd
sketch that a couple of places where you
might see that beginning to peak out
most Python systems start very simple
and they don't use any of this
functionality but instead they'll grow
towards having their own custom object
there'll be some set pattern for how all
the objects are designed what the
objects need to have they may use
mechanisms like in its subclass and its
subclasses or is the replacement for or
is the intended replacement for a wide
variety of uses of metaclasses and in
its subclass what you can do is you can
actually do things like you can add in
extra keyword arguments to your class
definition to define things that should
be automatically generated on that class
and so one thing that you could do is
you could make this resistor you know
automatically JSON serializable
automatically decodable from json and
you could provide guidance for how
that's done in the keyword arguments
when you derive this thing here I'm just
giving it some measure information so
maybe it'll be able to print out nicely
what the units are could do some unit
conversion that might be the use case
but that's what it's subclass is for now
the question is if I don't do this
explicitly am I going to end up doing
this implicitly and in my in my
experience most large production systems
in Python end up creating their own
object systems internally and they end
up not using the mechanisms provided to
you by Python and so they end up being
both as complicated as all the examples
that we've looked at so far but much
harder to understand because all of the
mechanisms employed are completely
ad-hoc that were just written on it as
needed and so the final guidance that I
would give you is that it is very
valuable to understand the details of
how all these hopes work it's very
valuable to understand how the Python
object model works because a large
production system not an analytical
system but a production system that has
analytical components will eventually
evolve in this direction and if you
don't understand all of the things that
we've talked about in this session
there's a very high likelihood that the
code will be just as messy and just as
complex as everything we've seen so far
but even harder to understand because it
won't use anything
language so I hope you enjoyed that
think that's all the time that we have
for this session that was objectionable
content
I'm James Powell thank you so much
[Applause]